new stuff
I think thinking about and appreciating
the time too instead of thinking about
kernels
if in a fine-tuning setup if you're
thinking about
um
kernels even plugging in a learned
kernel you know maybe you derive
something for a fixed kernel but then
you plug in the properties of the
learning kernel and see if that goals so
that sort of mixed kind of uh some
Theory but you plug in measured
quantities and it might be useful but I
think that fully doing a derivation
um first principles for future learning
for example these correlated and strong
interactions I mentioned I think it's
challenging I think
um from a physics perspective it's
usually so
one of the goals is to kind of have
effective theories so it's to you don't
want to have the full you know number of
Weights a number of parameter set of
variables in your theoretical
description you want to reduce they're
usually Define new sets of variables
um when you want to uh kind of talk
about something at a higher level so
it's possible that with some combination
of I think insight about the structure
of data and setting those feature
learning limits you could derive reduce
sets of basically coupled equations that
you could solve
um but it's I think it's challenging to
know what is universal in general about
that and what is very dependent on that
so I think uh I think there's it's
pretty challenging
let's think Jasmine again
[Music]
uh so next we have Sasha Rush from uh
Grinnell
what I really like about Sasha is that
he both kind of Blends the end of this
curiosity of the scientists but also can
really get things to work and uh has
worked with uh training really large
scale models but I actually don't know
which combination of those he's going to
tell us about today but either way I
think it's going to be really
interesting uh so let's welcome Sasha
yeah so today I'm going to uh try to
engage with some of the theories side of
this Workshop uh I'm have exactly the
opposite disclaimer of yazamin in that
uh I'm in natural language processing
researcher so the flaws come with that
and also the positives uh and I'm going
to engage with the same topic of neural
scaling laws so I'm gonna go through a
lot of the same material but um luckily
we used almost identical clip art so
it'll uh it'll work really well uh in
that in that structure
um so today I'm going to present work
that we've done mainly uh by Nicholas
moyninkoff uh this was work kind of with
hugging face and a bunch of other folks
um and um it's uh called scaling data
constrained language models uh we just
put it up in the archive about a month
ago so it's relatively recent work I'd
love to hear any comments or um
questions you may have about it
cool so let's talk about scaling laws
so um again I'm kind of coming at this
from a more practical point of view I'm
kind of interested in what sort of real
world questions we have when building
large language models that we need to
worry about and how scaling laws can
help us answer those questions
so specifically throughout the talk
we're going to have three terms we're
going to have model size training data
and training compute I'm going to be
entirely focused on training large
language models so that will be the kind
of main aspect to the talk
um and because they're Transformers
there's going to be a coefficient there
Alpha that's well known we can kind of
ignore it throughout the talk but in
practice it's something like six
so um given our model size given our
training data we can get our training
compute
um different models in NLP have kind of
changed these coefficients in different
ways leading to different numbers of
training compute we're going to measure
model size in number of parameters
training data in number of tokens and
training compute in floating Point
operations
so a model like Bert from 2018 which was
absolutely revolutionary from the NLP
perspective had about 109 million
parameters
250 billion training tokens and took 1.6
e to the 20th compute
flops sorry and so that's about 64 tpus
over about four days at that period of
time
since that point models have gone in
parameter size to about 540 billion
tokens have gone to trillions and flops
have gone much much larger this is about
the point where companies stop reporting
these numbers so I could give you the
rumors for where we are now but this is
the kind of last hard numbers I feel
kind of confident putting in a slide
um so in general this just describes the
relationship between these values we
have a kind of multiplicative
relationship between model size and
tokens leading to a number of flops
so given this scenario there are kind of
two high-level questions you might want
to ask
so imagine you're an executive at say
anthropic and you need to train a big
model you might ask what will the value
of kind of using more flops be
if I increase the number of tokens how
much return is that going to actually
give me is this worth it
the other question you might ask is one
of allocation
this is slightly different than the last
talk this looks into what's the right
balance between increasing tokens and
increasing number of parameters that you
might want to strike
we know that increasing both of these
can give us better loss but actually
determining what the ratio should be is
pretty important in practice if you get
it wrong it could lead to wasted pops
these are the kind of graphs we saw from
the the last talk these represent the
kind of scaling law of properties that
show that unbottlenecked by other
properties of the system increasing both
model size training data and also
compute leads to this power law
relationship
you can tell it's a power law because
both the axis here are log scale and we
get roughly a linear like output of our
underlying loss
so throughout the talk I'll just use
test loss as a proxy for how good our
large language model is
at the end of the talk I'll engage a bit
more with actual accuracy of these
models in practice
but the main kind of idea here is that
putting in more compute helps and it
helps for both of these quantities model
size and training data
when talking about allocation I'm mostly
going to utilize the terms and graphs
from this paper chinchilla
chinchilla provides kind of concrete
decals extrapolated from a large set of
empirical experiments that try to
predict how we should allocate between
adding more parameters and adding more
tokens
so this will be the main kind of graph
that we'll utilize throughout the talk
on the x-axis we have training data and
number of tokens
on the y-axis we have model size
and the labels represent the amount of
compute these represent
these four models shown here are four
different models and what they decided
on this allocation
the chinchilla paper argues that these
models made incorrect allocation choices
for the number of flops they utilized
and showed that if you utilize those
flops instead with an equal balance
between model size and training data you
would yield what they call a compute
optimal language model
so taking into account the cost of the
flops we're deciding to allocate it to a
smaller number of parameters but more
tokens and here we got a model that
exceeds a one trillion tokens and has
kind of led to Future models using more
and more tokens for these systems
this will be kind of the main
inspiration for this Talk itself and
this graph represents kind of how we're
thinking about this problem and the
questions we're interested in answering
we can write this down with the formula
um this formula gives us an estimate of
the loss that we'll achieve based on the
model size and the training data
so assuming kind of other hyper
parameters are kind of fixed or kind of
optimized for we're interested in
estimating what our loss will be when we
vary these two quantities
so throughout the talk we'll use n to
represent model size and D to represent
the number of tokens and this will give
us a functional form that represents the
following power law
so we're interested in estimating l
taking into account model size n
data d
and these five terms that we're going to
fit to a set of empirical experiments
in the chinchilla paper they give a
rough kind of um sense of what these
three terms represent
so e is kind of a lower bound that's the
true
um uh loss of language the true entropy
of language
we can't do better than that
the first term is obviously entirely in
terms of the model size itself
represents roughly the types of models
that we might be able to learn
the second term represents the fact that
we only see a finite number of tokens
and therefore we're kind of bound in how
much we can learn about the underlying
system
you can think about it that way or you
can think about it as just extrapolating
from a lot of experiments and trying to
decide how you should actually train
your model
when you fit these constants on real
experiments you get that Alpha is
roughly equal to Beta
which explains the equal scaling in the
previous slide
yeah you mean uh I mean but there was
some difference are you saying now it's
actually the same
um
this is just describing the chinchilla
paper I think um I think maybe maybe I
just meet it in I don't mean in any deep
sense just in that it's roughly yeah
that's correct yeah
uh maybe maybe more equal than
previously had been yeah noted right
of the language itself but it is the
limit of what can be learned using the
architecture if we change the
architecture and like try different type
of networks it's possible that we get to
a much lower loss like even in the case
of infinite resources is it possible
that it will never actually get to that
so my understanding is that's what the
first term represents
so so this this first term here
represents the fact that your model
might not be able to achieve that
whereas the last term really does
represent the true entropy of language
no the interpretation that's an
interpretation it's an interpretation I
I yeah he's making the point that maybe
Transformers will never get to the twin
regardless of scaling yeah that sounds
right to me
um let's see I'm I'm mostly reciting how
they talk about this in section c of
their paper
um yeah
but yeah it's possible in practice Yeah
Yeah I think that's yeah
yeah um can I talk about it later but in
practice
scale data
and you know that's that works well
perspective that how you view that yeah
it's a really good point so uh this is
someone orthogonal to the point of this
work but I think it's actually
arguably the most important conclusion
that's come out of this which is that uh
notably the Llama models make a kind of
conscious decision to scale data more
than compute so roughly that means they
end up in this region of the graph
and the argument they give is that
inference time when you actually use the
model Downstream is more important than
actually compute optimality so therefore
it's worth getting a worse model making
a bad allocation because of some
Downstream constraint
now I think that is critical in the
sense of like when you make these
decisions but it's a purposeful decision
to solve a kind of different
optimization
yeah we'll talk about that a little bit
more
cool yeah and um and just to give you a
sense of the scale llama two is at 2
trillion parameters so it's roughly
around there
um but with only uh 70 billion
parameters so around there
okay
so given this background I want to talk
about a kind of unique and
counter-intuitive problem which is that
well we're running out of data
um and I think this is just a
fascinating problem for me and kind of
just thinking about how kind of crazy
these models are
so this is from a paper that graphs uh
kind of estimates of the amount of
tokens available
and estimations of when we will actually
run out of data itself
so there are two lines plotted here one
line kind of makes an estimate of uh
scaling based on the actual models
people are building
and the other line makes an estimate
based on the increase in compute just
from Nvidia producing more flops for a
given price
and I think there are two things that
are interesting about this graph
um one is you can't totally see it here
but there's a kind of very wide variance
so it's kind of unclear exactly when
this will come about or actually how
much data there really is
um but the other thing that's
interesting is that the amount of data
is not really growing at a very fast
rate when you consider these scales so
it's not like if you just kind of
continue producing tokens it's going to
catch up uh there's just kind of a large
pool of data it's increasing at a
relatively slow rate whereas the kind of
actual compute is doubling in such a way
that it's going to need more data if you
believe in follow out these laws
um this is a little bit abstract so it
can be a little bit more practical
so some of the estimates of kind of
um of colors like Fermi estimations of
given quantities are that if you take
kind of high quality books that are
available uh come in an open source way
there are about 1 trillion tokens
oh sorry yeah 1.6 trillion if you take
all the academic papers that's about one
trillion tokens
other sources like Wikipedia are
extremely high quality but they're
actually much fewer tokens than you
might imagine
um and so if you think about these in
terms of the scales people are reaching
there aren't that many more orders of
magnitude available
yeah it's not really necessarily
relevant to a topic but there's this
tough history
and it's done better for the
summarization yeah so
syntheticator something one can do
is that even going to the hotel I would
love to hear agent talk about it more
but my understanding is that there's
nowhere near kind of uh evidence that
synthetic data can kind of solve this
kind of problem that for like specific
tasks you can construct things in
particular way but we certainly haven't
seen anyone create like orders of
magnitude more synthetic text
I want to distinguish that from text
generated from already good models that
seems to be effective at training
smaller models but I haven't seen
anything where you've kind of like
actually increased the order of
magnitude by Generation
Um but if you agent's in the room I'd
love to hear if you did great
um I I've only seen successful cases
with the task specific scenarios
um who knows what uh some other crazy
people with a lot of compute may be able
to uh pursue but yeah I think that's yet
to be seen that's great I'm gonna get
that tattoo to my arm who knows with
crazy people with lots of compute will
be able to do yeah
yeah so maybe I want to argue a bit
against the data constrained thing
um mainly thinking about like
distillation uh uh using Chain of
Thought or other kind of like basically
if you can do anything at inference time
to make your model smarter than it would
be by default then this gives you a
source of synthetic data because you can
kind of get that model to do things and
then distill down to the base model so
it sounds like this should be a pretty
ready source of synthetic data and
there's like some empirical work saying
that this or like showing that this does
improve model performance yeah so I'm
actually
um let's have this conversation I think
I'm not going to use the whole hour I'd
love to talk about this more
um I think that this Talk's going to be
relatively empirical on this one
specific thing so I want to talk about
these other ideas because that is kind
of where I want to get to but I want to
argue kind of even within my constraints
what we can learn yeah
it's basically on this page I'm also
kind of against the idea of data
constraint because for all the data we
are talking about here this is online
data and we know that only a specific
population gets access to Internet so we
are talking about like constraint in a
way that uh online data is limited but
your next slide is like if we think
about like a real world and a lot of
other populations who are not
represented on internet who don't have
access to Internet and also other
modalities that seems to open a lot of
space for potential data uh enrichment
so let's do the following let's let's
have this conversation I'm going to say
time at the end to talk about it
I want to engage with the kind of
physics asymptotic mindset just for the
talk so assuming you buy the scaling
wall stuff I want to kind of play
through this idea and then we can talk
about what to do about it okay cool any
other questions about these um
these first things
great okay so let me just also mention
because there's a lot of code a
surprising amount of code there's about
14 trillion tokens on GitHub
um a lot of evidence that the code can
actually be used even in regular
language models that are mostly natural
language
that's a good thing the bad thing is
that if you want to train a model for a
specific language things get much worse
so this project originated because some
of the researchers are training a
Finnish specific language model
um this was about uh where they were
able to collect about 38 billion tokens
so now we're several orders of magnitude
less
and you might argue that Y is it
necessary to create a giant language
model for every language but I think
people in Finland want to do this it's
very important and so I think um I think
whether or not you agree with that it is
something people are thinking about
okay
great so um let's save these questions
for the end I do want to get back to
them
cool
this talk today is about a very simple
idea I want to talk about
epox
this seems like a very basic idea in
machine learning we often just train the
model on the same data multiple times
however this seems to have become a kind
of like
bad word in the large language model
training literature
if you read the gp3 paper they very
clearly say that data are sampled
without replacement during training
now they do repeat some specific sources
like Wikipedia but they make very clear
choices about what they repeat and they
avoid it when they don't need to
in the Palm paper they say we train all
three models on exactly one Epoch of the
data and choose the mixing portion to
avoid repeating data in any sub command
now I think these kind of papers kind of
made people think that something will
really go wrong if we repeat the data
multiple times
but if we're in some sense running low
on data it seems like a natural thing to
do
so in this paper we wanted to explore
what happened if you repeat data and
just kind of make empirical observations
of the scaling law under this regime
the chinchilla paper they were not using
one they were
they never repeat the data yeah well I'm
thinking of a difference
okay so
um we're going to do the following we're
going to run very controlled experiments
on a very large scale
so we had access to
a large supercomputer and we're able to
run many different large language models
for this paper we ran 300 training of
large language models and we run under
the following settings
so we're going to vary the model size
from 2.8 billion parameters to 8.7
billion parameters
the training data here represents the
chinchilla optimal number of tokens for
those model sizes
and on the left you see the amount of
compute so a large amount of compute but
not really out to the scale what we're
seeing a giant large language models at
the moment
for each of these we're going to train
eight different models and we're going
to vary the amount of data that is
repeated
so we're going to basically
subsample the data and run multiple
epochs over the same tokens
all the other decals are in the paper
but the key thing to note are that
they're all using a standard
architecture
they're all using standard hyper
parameters basically adapted from the
chinchilla paper
and I'm going to show experiments mostly
on the C4 data set which is a relatively
clean data set of web crawl data we also
have other experiments in the paper with
other data sets
okay so just to give you a sense of the
data setting when I say Epoch I don't
mean multiple epochs on the same amount
of unique tokens I mean keeping flops
fixed
how can we split the data such that it
is computed with multiple fogs so when I
say seven epochs that means the same
number of flops as one Epoch but just
that I cut off the amount of unique data
earlier and then repeat it
this is a point of confusion so I just
want to make sure it's clear exactly
what I'm doing
so all these models we run for exactly
the same number of flops
but I'm changing the amount of unique
data
so here are the conclusions
so three different runs with different
parameters
within each one of these columns
everything is the same number of flops
when you train with different number of
parameters on
um one Epoch so all unique data you get
the following loss curves
this is validation loss on the left
number of training tokens on the bottom
and final loss of the final point
so as might be expected for chinchilla
compute optimal models going from 2.8
billion parameters to 8.7 billion
parameters leads to a relatively large
increase in accuracy or a decrease in
loss so we go from 2.6 to 2.4
now I run the same size models but two
epochs
so that means I only had half as many
unique tokens but I ran through them
twice
you see very similar curves
now I do three epochs
and four outbox
so it's for that box I only had 25
percent of the unique tokens
but if I use the same amount of flops I
get roughly the same amount of loss
the same same value
when I get up to about seven there is a
kind of noticeable Gap here
and when I get to about 14 the loss kind
of tells off much earlier
I keep on going up to 44 I start seeing
kind of instability or overfitting or
kind of go outside the regime itself
so main conclusion is similar
performance for a few amount of repeats
and when you go out of scope you get bad
performance
yeah
is there a way to quantify this in terms
of say like the effective amount of data
you have if you're doing say two or
three epics right I guess it's like a
little bit hard to eyeball but maybe it
looks like for three epics it's sort of
as if I had maybe like
42 billion tokens instead of 55 billion
this is a great idea Jacob I really we
really should do this give me two slides
but yeah I think you get where we're
going yeah yeah another question was uh
um I mean I've seen some of these before
and some other shows but
uh do you see any kind of overfitting in
terms of trend versus renovation
um yeah so this is validation loss I
think uh this is definitely but the gap
between training oh oh great question
um
you know it's really interesting
actually because people normally run one
Epoch I don't think of that difference
for language models but you're right
here that should matter I don't remember
if those numbers are in the paper or not
but we should have included those
because they matter a lot more here but
I don't know offhand
I mean you really would expect that
since you're seeing 44 epochs you'd
think the train data the train loss
would be really really low right and
maybe another related question was did
you check on the downstream evaluations
that that is coming but yes they do
behave as you might expect
yeah so for these uh like 44 epics
results you see these kind of classic
overfitting curves where you get this
sort of catastrophic failure
I wish these cards ran out for for
longer because I'm curious if these
um
more data it's not clear that you're
going to see the same catastrophic
overfitting Behavior do you think that
if you just run these cards out for for
many many moderations you see the same
overstating with the larger data sets as
well or if you like eventually you get a
critical mass of data where
you become somewhat stable though for
different models well just to be clear
though we want to be really careful so
there's actually less unique data here
for 44. right so there's more tokens but
less unique tokens yes so there are some
numbers we'll get to that kind of answer
some of the questions you're asking but
I do want to note that in this work
we're less concerned about the kind of
overfitting case because we didn't
really try to make this work we just
used roughly the same hyper parameters
what I'm really interested in is kind of
this regime here and kind of kind of
quantifying what what happens in this
space
cool
um so uh this phenomenon holds in other
data sets it's not unique to C4 we see a
similar curve
now again I don't want to make any point
that this is like a deep thought right
what we're seeing here looks like what
you might imagine from kind of training
with a kind of standard machine Learning
System we're just kind of validating
this for large language models and
trying to quantify it
cool okay so
um getting to the question Jacob asked I
think the next natural thought is how do
we quantify the effective amount of data
that we have when repeating
so this really matters because when kind
of deciding how to allocate our flops we
know what to do if we have infinite
unique data but we have to decide what
we're going to do in the case where we
have a constrained amount of data to
work with
so we're going to use a relatively
simple model which is we're going to
think about data having exponential
decay
so the analogy here is to something like
a half-life where every time we use the
data it decays in some exponential form
we have some term Delta that's going to
correspond to the decay of the data on
repeated use
so just to kind of make this a little
bit more tangible the model is that
we're going to have this new term which
we call D Prime
the D Prime represents the effective
amount of data that we're actually
utilizing under repeat
and that's going to differ from the
unique data U which is the actual data
we were able to collect
we're gonna have another term Rd which
represents the number of repetitions of
the data itself
so just to make this a little bit more
tangible if Delta was equal to one it
would mean that we wouldn't have to
worry about this problem at all
um oh sorry the opposite adult is equal
one then we wouldn't be able to repeat
the data at all it would use all of its
value on the first use
if Delta is equal to zero then we can
repeat the data forever and it's
effectively the perfect world where we
don't have a problem at all
I mean if Delta is equal to 0.5 then
repeated data retains 50 of its value
to simplify things we're going to think
about things in a compounding form so
when we write out the equation we're
going to use this form instead where
instead of measuring Delta we're going
to have a term which we call R star d
and that's going to correspond to the
number of times we can repeat the data
before we get a catastrophic failure for
basically it gets very bad
so if R star is equal to zero that's the
case where repeated data is worth
nothing
um if R star is equal to Infinity
repeated data is as good as new
and as we saw from the previous
experiments the r Stars
uh kind of somewhere somewhere less than
44 for our underlying uh uh language
modeling
great
so now let's look a little bit about how
we fit these terms in practice uh yeah
yeah can you go back to the functional
formula yeah wait so if R star D is
infinity isn't the same you get infinite
data even when Rd is finite or I think I
maybe it's just not the person yeah
that's right so it's um I think uh R
star D is roughly the same as if Delta
was equal to zero but like say like Rd
is like two so I've only repeated the
data twice then it seems like d Prime
should only be like two times U
even in the best case but insane it
would be like in three times you
I see
um
maybe that are the first star should be
just r d
um
good question uh I don't think I'm gonna
be able to do this on the fly but I will
look in and make sure I don't have a
typo or anything okay
yeah
whatever change the learning rate
because we are repeating the data like
for example like maybe I repeat the same
data twice but I use after learning
exactly the same result as if I train
the data once with twice yeah it's a
good question so
um we mostly just stuck with the kind of
chinchilla or an adapted version of the
chinchilla formula for these terms the
chinchilla learning rate is a little bit
complex so um uh the the details of
exactly how that work are important but
at this scale we weren't really able to
experiment too much with kind of
different learning rates or things of
that form so so it is possible that the
optimal hyper parameters for creating
the model actually change when you are
working with repeatedly compared
I think that's possible yeah I would
love for someone to explore that more
um
okay so um I think this slide
um uh gives us a sense of the final
return
um so what I'm going to do here is I'm
going to plot the final point of the
previous experiments so this is exactly
the same data that we saw before just
shown in a different form
so each of these points represents a a
different version of the model trained
with a different percentage of unique
tokens
um the kind of a line here represents
the kind of perfect world where
everything was the same just based on
the parameters and the flops
and the line on the top represents a
kind of strong form of decay
each of the points that we show here
represent our empirical experiments and
the line represents the kind of
predicted version of this under the
decay equation I showed you on the
previous slide
here's a version for a larger model so
this is with 4.2 billion parameters
and here it is with 8.7 billion
parameters
so for all three of these we see a
relatively good fit for using our kind
of exponential decay of the data itself
we can also look at the predicted loss
for different number of epochs in
practice so for a model of 2.8 billion
parameters the line the dotted line
represents what you'd expect from using
unique data to get our new tokens
and the predicted line represents what
we expect from repeating the same data
starting from just around 100 billion
tokens
so we see that around that for epox
things are relatively close to having
unique tokens but as we get out to more
and more epochs the kind of marginal
value of more repeats becomes relatively
low particularly when you consider the
additional flops required to utilize
them
here's the curve for 4.2 billion and for
8.7 billion
great
um okay so now let's go just through
what this means for the chinchilla
formula itself
so at this point you probably can guess
what we're going to do in terms of kind
of predicting those lines from the
previous slide
we're going to take d
and we're going to instead put in the
effective amount of data D Prime that we
think will happen under the decay of
using repeats so we just substitute in
our D Prime formula from the previous
slide to get that part of the equation
uh we also found that it was necessary
to substitute in for n
um to take into account the fact that
the parameters are being learned from
less effective data
so we have a similar exponential decay
here on the parameters itself
we have a Min here to represent the
value we get from the unique number of
parameters so you need tokens learning
those parameters yeah
is this something incredibly derived or
Theory I mean not clear to me than this
they should happen there's some effect
but the precise functional form
um so we we took basically the same
functional form yes um I agree that uh
this I I don't I don't fully understand
the kind of causal uh uh reason here I
think that the theory was something like
the feature learning that goes on in the
first term will be weaker because of
repeating the data
um but but beyond that this is just a
kind of empirical but I guess yeah the
question is it fits this fits yeah oh
that's interesting yeah
so what what are the three parameters
like just R star and r r star and then
our start yeah it's a good question
actually so we fit a b Alpha Beta and E
with the same uh the same way that they
get into children you just use the 185
results to fit those exactly yeah yeah
um once you add in the multi-apoc the
only new parameters are R star and R
star D are okay
foreign
yeah
um cool any other questions they're
great questions
yeah
so the idea here is if you can repeat it
10 times or so you know without much
loss now if you were to change your
hyper parameter on I call it the gain of
the gradient descent I don't know what
it's called but if you were to change
that you know it took for a little bit
more feedback then would it saturate at
a lower number like you know are those
numbers related
I love that people are asking this
question I don't have a good answer for
it
if it motivates work in this area it
would be awesome
these experiments are large enough that
we really just took what they said in
chinchilla adapted into our data and ran
at the scale but could you change that
hyper parameter and see what happens is
that a doable experiment uh with enough
compute one could do that yeah yeah
absolutely and I should mention that in
the chinchilla paper they do change the
hyper parameter setting from previous
large language models and I do find that
makes a difference so I don't want to
say that these are kind of universal
properties of the universe they're more
kind of just empirical tools
yeah yeah related questions so yeah in
the chinchilla paper they were more
methodical with Hyper parameters plotted
out the curves and take the minimum
you're just staying with them you're not
doing that search again that's right
so there might be something to squeeze
out there yeah absolutely yeah
um it's a really good point again I just
want to note that it's hard to do these
things simply because the economics of
running these is is very tough yeah
especially that you're limited uh by the
keep taking through these large language
models but so a lot of these results
seems like perhaps they might apply to
smaller models as well
yeah we haven't tried to scale it down
as far as I know yeah
um cool
um oh yeah
age the rationale for them
yeah so the rationale is that the N
Prime term represents how kind of good
the model could be in these settings and
that we think in a kind of feature
learning style model the repeats of data
is going to kind of limit uh what could
be learned here
um I know that's not super satisfying so
I think maybe the other argument is it's
a kind of empirical question that if you
think the first term would maybe stay
exactly the same then the r star value
should maybe reflect that
okay
great
um okay so I have a couple more
interesting results I want to show and
then we can talk about some of the
questions about data constraints
so we did this we get values for R star
D and R star n that's what I showed you
on the previous slide
okay next I want to talk about this
question of allocation
so a practical question you might have
is how to decide how often you should
repeat and how big your model should be
so given the chinchilla curve if we're
going to repeat data because it's
limited what actually happens to the
curve itself do we want to repeat more
often or do we want to add more
parameters
I must say this was not intuitive to me
of Which choice you might make if I only
have say a hundred billion tokens I'm
actually wasn't sure what I should do in
practice
so what we did is we kind of plot this
data
um this is with a hundred million unique
tokens varying the model size and data
repetitions
so every point on this graph represents
a different choice of repetitions versus
model parameters given 100 million
unique tokens
the colors of the point represent the
final loss and the Contour plot
represents where the loss was kind of
minimal for these models
so recall that the amount of flops is
multiplicative so either going to the
right or up will cost us more flops in
practice
this black star here represents the kind
of only using unique tokens chinchilla
Point whereas this white star here
represents a good loss on the model
itself
so when you fit the curve or the formula
we saw on the previous slide to this
data you get Contours of the following
form
so it basically shows that as you add
more flops you get better
but it also shows the kind of ratio of
adding more parameters versus repeating
the data more times
and in particular if we draw the
chinchilla curves over this data we can
see that equal scaling gives us
something like this but our formula
predicts that we should roughly be
repeating the data more often
before adding more parameters to the
underlying system
so we actually start getting a better
loss about here and kind of scales below
the chinchilla line
unlike chinchilla where you can keep on
going at infinitum for our curve it kind
of peeks out at a given point and this
corresponds to the point where our hyper
parameters seem wrong and we leave
outside the regime and kind of go into
overfitting mode or whatever you want to
call that
cool
um so just to summarize this is the
hypothetical chinchilla line
our Contours predict that we should
scale the repetitions faster then we
scale the number of parameters and this
corresponds to the fact that our R star
D value is higher than our R star n
any questions about these results
that's right yes
yeah
we gave them similar names because
they're kind of analogous terms yeah
yeah
kind of extrapolation experiments with
these fitting fitting experiments so fit
on small scale in your regime and
evaluated on the logger scale yeah
we tried some extrapolation experiments
where we fit these curves on the small
scale and tried extrapolating to a
larger scale so uh for these we start
with uh 25 billion tokens as our data
constraint
and we run two larger models so these
two models have the same number of flops
but one of them utilizes a kind of naive
adaptation of the chinchilla formula
whereas the other kind of slopes
downward utilizing the data scaling law
that we predict
what we find is that for the same amount
of flops we see that this model gives us
a better loss this looks small but it's
um relatively large at this sort of a
low loss for these models
um and I think this is kind of as
expected from the kind of smaller
results that repeating the data a bit
more often and using fewer parameters
seems to give a better loss in practice
here
cool and I again I don't really want to
claim any kind of mechanistic reason why
this happens this is kind of mostly an
extrapolation experiment as Jonathan
noted utilizing our small experiments to
try to scale this in practice
yeah
cool
um one really neat consequence of this
is that we're able to go back and kind
of counter factually examine previous
papers
there is one large language model that
seemingly repeated data and that was
because the kind of data scale was
already exhausted so this work on
Galactica it was particularly trained on
scientific papers and when you train on
scientific papers there's just a limited
amount of them and so they decided at
this point here to repeat the data 4.25
times
but note that what they decided to do
was actually to add more parameters in
order to repeat less so they went above
the chinchilla curve
so I think what we're arguing is that
they may have been able to go below the
chinchilla curve and had a better loss
they additionally trained a much larger
model
and repeated 4.25 times and in this
point we think they could have done even
better by repeating something like 12
times with a much smaller model
so I think this is um it remains to be
seen whether this is true in practice
but we think the kind of predicted
values from this experiment may have
actually helped to kind of produce a
better a large language
crates
um okay so I I do want to leave time for
questions I'm going to do about two
minutes more
um on some of the other experiments in
the paper
so
um in in some sense I I think these
results are nice in that they give us an
empirical thing we can do in the next
couple years to get extra orders of
magnitude
but they're also kind of pessimistic in
that they say well this maybe only lets
us double one more time or two more
times
we wanted to look at other complementary
strategies that might be useful in
practice
so we looked at a couple in the paper
one is to utilize code data to try to
fill out to get extra tokens
and the other is to revise the filtering
process of large language models
now the second one gets into some of the
specifics of how these models are
trained so I don't want to go into that
too much so we just don't have time to
go into the details but roughly it's
going to alter the way that these data
sets are constructed in order to get
more effective tokens or to get less
effective tokens and repeat them more
often
I think this code one is actually a
little bit more interesting in practice
yeah so that's a one-time thing or you
are adjusting along the way
you say one more time that that you know
you're looking at the perplexity filter
one time thing one time yeah so um we're
gonna we're gonna remove the default
perplexity filter for these data sets
put on say a higher perplexity filter so
get like more high quality data and
repeat it more often
something like that
so like a weaker model is that's giving
you a perplexity oh yeah assume we have
a magical perplexity model that we get
to start with yeah which is more
powerful I actually don't know in
practice let's say more powerful just
for yeah
foreign
really good question
um if
some of the experiments do deduplication
which I guess is a very weak form of
diversity otherwise we're just using
default kind of common crawl uh
processes so we kind of take however
they decided to construct the data set
okay
um so this is my last kind of um uh
experimental slide
um so
um there's a lot of variants here
because these are actually run not on
loss but on a collection of uh basically
Benchmark data sets uh these Benchmark
data sets are they're kind of NLP data
sets but you should be aware that a lot
of NLP data sets kind of look like
reasoning sort of tasks
um so they include lots of underlying
skills
um the purple line here represents the
repeating data curves we've roughly seen
so far so instead of showing perplexity
this shows Downstream accuracy but the
graph looks pretty similar to what we've
seen so this is with full unique data
this is with repeat this is with repeat
and then this is like lots to repeat and
then it tells off
the the main point we want to make here
is that code seems to work quite well
that we can maintain pretty high
accuracy by replacing a large number of
tokens with code it seems to
um basically keep similar curves as
repeating data and in fact for some of
the tasks it seems to help a lot
um but there does seem to be evidence
that kind of filling up half of the
remaining tokens with code is pretty
useful for improving these systems
we have some experiments on perplexity
filtering and deduplication in the paper
I don't want to draw too many
conclusions from these now because uh
some of the details are important to
understand them
um but we find that this is pretty data
set specific but that it seems like
things like filtering with perplexity
and then repeating can be effective and
should be explored in future work
um
are any of these Downstream performance
uh the downstream task
involve code style understanding or is
it just that somehow code happens to
have natural language in it because
people write lots of comment or do you
have anything yeah I have lots of
thoughts um
none of them involve code
I don't think code has that much natural
language
but a lot of the tasks to me feel like
basically code tasks so a bunch of the
tasks are like these like kind of like
like baby or something like these like
tasks that are expressed in natural
language but really they're about kind
of matching two things and putting them
in so to me they feel not so different
than synthetic tasks or code tasks
that makes sense
so that's the task on which you're
seeing Improvement yeah like baby yeah
which um
despite being I I I'm an author in that
paper and I am not super proud of it but
yeah it is like a weird task in that way
yeah uh yeah actually give me one
millisecond I I just I just want to
conclude so um uh this is where this is
uh kind of the main conclusion from the
talk and then
um the last thing I'll mention is that
people have been using this on
Downstream tasks so we actually uh the
the authors of this paper were able to
train a Finnish language model they
repeated it eight times and they see
kind of actual use from this in practice
so it's still not massive massive number
of tokens but you do get a practical
amount of effective tokens in practice
um that all being said I think there was
lots of really great conversation about
this yesterday and I don't want to make
any claim that I think we're inherently
like screwed uh I think there's lots of
other orthogonal ways that we might be
able to get more data tokens but I do
want to know that like a lot of the
progress so far has come from just
scaling the same Transformer model and I
do think it is interesting that maybe
that is like kind of getting your some
kind of end point
uh and so hopefully works like this
encourage people to try more creative
ways to get value out of data to get
value out of other modalities and to
kind of come up with evaluations that
are better than these kind of just
asymptotic uh evaluations so why don't I
end there and then we'll take some more
questions
[Applause]
yeah
it's code special or is one way to make
progress on Finnish even if the fins
don't like it to augment the Finish data
by two times as much English data
um
it certainly is worth trying
I'm not 100 sure that the reasons people
want to train language models in one
language are entirely like uh perplexity
based like there may be other reasons
why people want to train language models
just in one language but I agree that if
we're just caring about perplexity it
does seem like uh multilingual models
are more effective way of doing it
yeah
I I don't understand really precisely
what you mean by training off code are
you taking the raw python code or is it
filtered some way crop I think so that
means it must get really good with if
and then and four keywords when you're
trading off all that code I think the
lexical things are trivial it gets that
right away I think it's it's probably
learning all sorts of things like
copying long-distance relationships or
kind of um basic mathematical reasoning
we looked at headset have to do with
like natural language yeah I think
that's what I was saying earlier is that
we're not measuring natural language
perplexity we're measuring
accuracy on tasks that NLP researchers
came up with and some of those have
properties that require similar skills
as code is my hearing yeah
all right so when you're repeating the
data is this just a matter of like
multiple epochs the model hasn't
converged in some sense
and by repeating the data you're just
getting close you're doing less early
stopping in some ways
yeah I think that's a fair point I think
the reason I didn't use language like
convergence is because when talking
about scaling laws you're actively
considering the number of flops and I
feel like that feels slightly different
so we're we're interested not just in
convergence but in like the actual cost
of running it right right so we're
getting we're getting more value in some
sense out of the repeat yeah right I'm
just wondering because running multiple
epochs it sort of convolves the
regularization you get from early
stopping with the amount of data but
also I have a more general question here
which is why not subsample the data in
each Epoch rather than sub sampling once
and then repeating because we're
literally assuming that you just do not
have more data oh okay yeah like the
setting we care about is like yeah
this all being said I don't I mean
people in this room tell me more but I
don't know how to think about what
regularization means when you have 500
billion parameters right my terminology
may be out of date in that regarding
point
going back to the code uh questions
um I might have missed it but you were
focusing on the fact that the tasks are
somehow code like
are you saying that if you were to look
at perplexity you don't see the same
results yeah certainly if you train on
half code your perplexity on language
doesn't go down in the same way but that
makes sense to me because it's out of
out of distribution yeah but does it go
down
that's a good question I I think there
are results in the paper I don't need
Epsilon I I don't actually don't know of
him yeah yeah can I think of these
results as a kind of certificate on the
inefficiency of SGD as a learning
algorithm you have to look sometimes to
get the result yeah yeah but I mean we
didn't invent that right people have
like like that's certainly no and yeah
maybe it suggests that there's room for
improvement fair enough although I mean
um man like STD has survived a lot of uh
attempts to Dethrone it so yeah I mean
it's also worth mentioning that c bar 10
models are trained for like 3 000 and
you know so like
this is in terms of inefficiency of SGD
is incredibly mild right but yeah
yeah and I think when we talk about
efficiency we should talk about flop
efficiency as well so like you come with
a crazier method but it might require
more flops and somewhere
um when you're getting like smaller data
sets are you just randomly sampling them
from the larger one it's exactly this
so so like for the seven uh epochs like
are you just taking like uh one seventh
like random sound so no it starts the
same it's we just cut it like this
huh
oh like you just take like the first
seventh and then yeah we we like Shuffle
once and then yeah so like the diversity
of like the smaller like if I were to
just have a smaller data set like in
this the diversity comes from a larger
data set right oh that's a good point
yes we don't make any Claim about like
if you had a small data set and it was
all in one domain and what would happen
yeah it really is assuming example did
you have a question do you want to talk
about some of the bigger stuff oh uh not
bigger Okay so so I'm curious about the
per capacity filter
um because this seems to be very
um like a strategic choice for people
training large language models like
yesterday on the gpt4 talk was talking
about that they only used top 20
percentage somehow
um if it's very sensitive I guess how
does it play a role in this process what
has been filtered out if the filter
optimized publicity then our protruding
also optimize publicity is that a
problem or issue that's a really good
point and I think it relates to some of
the conversations yesterday about like
implicit distillation that you might be
getting benefits from having like higher
quality data uh whereas we also Dee and
I were talking about how some of these
perplexity filters May filter out
um dialects or kind of I don't know
parts of the distribution you really
care about a lot a priority before
training
um that being said I think Colin maybe
you can answer this slightly better do
you have a sense of
uh like what what how people should
think about perplexity filters in
practice well I think I mean I don't
want to zoom out too much but I think it
just kind of into the question of like
what high quality data is because any
discussion of how much data is available
implicitly assumes that there's some
good data and some bad data right
because there are web pages that get
filtered out when you're creating a data
set that are just like random characters
we would all say that's bad that's low
quality data but if we don't then our
data set is larger and like so you can't
have it as much how much data do we have
without defining what high quality is
but you can't Define what high quality
is it's an incredibly nebulous yeah and
like perplexity filtering for sure is
not a proxy for high quality uh exactly
but I don't maybe it's reasonable
um I mean I think like I also think it's
a it's a question of diminishing returns
like again you look if you just look at
the data that you've scraped some of it
is garbage you come up with some
heuristics to get rid of the garbage
that gets rid of a bunch of
data but then as you add more heuristics
you start to uh filter up stuff that's
not actually garbage and perplexity
filtering I think is far enough down the
chain of filtering that uh that we can't
be confident anymore that it's doing
what we want it to do and it says is
Nicholas Carlini here I think I saw him
yesterday let me see I think he has
other views on this as well well if
you're interested in this topic he also
has written a lot about this
uh yeah
oh yeah sure so you know when you say
that you're not working you know an
actual natural language process
can I ask more like a question
about a motivation yeah this is
this is really I guess motivated from
you know a port of making uh that chat
three comment about sampling without
replacement which to me infers that it's
a hypergeometric distribution
So like um and when you imply that
you're using something like a half-life
Decay and this is more like the sodium
distribution I'm a little curious then
no should we expect to see more
personian like distribution features
what you're doing okay not
hypergeometric distribution features
yeah
um let's see I I wasn't really making
any I I hear what you're saying I wasn't
making that claim I think I was making a
much weaker claim of just that like they
were trying not to literally repeat uh
as opposed to because
I don't think they're doing anything
like interestingly hyper geometric uh I
think they're just literally just not
they're just saying like we have so much
data why don't we use it all and that
will be the most effective way of going
about the process
so we should uh probably break here so
let's thank Sasha again
[Applause]
uh so there should be I think
Refreshments outside will reconvene in
20 minutes